[Music]
[Music]
this is Justin Schmidt yeah my name is
Justin Schmidt
he's an entomologist and I'm an
entomologist
I basically studied stinging insects
he's been stung by a lot of insects I've
probably been stung at least a thousand
times he reviews insect stings the way a
somali a reviews wine pure intense
brilliant pain like walking or flaming
charcoal as a three-inch nail embedded
in your heel which insect was that
that's the bullet and this is his lab in
Tucson this is his harvester ant this is
his vinegaroon this is a tarantula hawk
these are some more harvester ants in a
park near his lab he is the creator of
the Schmidt pain scale the Schmidt pain
scale is basically a scale to rate the
painfulness of stinging insects on a
scale of one to four but one would be a
sweat B two would be something like a
yellow jacket was the three would be
something like a harvester ant and a
four would be a perennial hog how bad is
a 4 4 is absolutely excruciating the
debilitating incapacitating just shuts
you down just absolute sheer pain
there's just nothing you can really do
about that I don't think I'd want to be
stung by a whole bunch of different for
I don't think I could endure that for
very long let's be clear Justin Schmidt
doesn't just go out and get stung on
purpose it's just that he's dedicated
his life to studying well my passion is
insects and stinging insects in
particular yeah I get stung but that's
that's all just part of the passion you
know what that gives me data you know
thing helps me in understanding what the
insects doing and I get to be out in the
sunshine and out in the rain out in the
environment studying these magnificent
beautiful insects just just such a joy I
can't imagine anything I'd rather do
more
[Music]
do you see the budget I had a second
Granger
[Music]
Milverton came at akashavani yo Sonali
Gionta Nagy Tilly got an identical Oki
binary Manticore sorta deep in the
Himalayan mountains about 80 miles
outside of Katmandu the Bujang village
takes part in a death-defying tradition
all in the name of honey
[Music]
yo Polly but I'm gonna journey or not
it's on your honey cavity stone that it
but procuring this precious honey takes
more than just strength a team of honey
hunters assembles twice a year to
prepare and Madan he leads the pack
finally you just the Emerald gonti jadi
here are your gum time sixty boil you
hear about how you gotta go you're a
monocot even a movie theater of this
deep pass an online today ancient
customs are still closely followed
before each hunt Madan must visit the
village guru to receive His blessing
Pinero Buddha by oh no no se quedó baba
domalix each ad era I was oval egg and
era tikka masala dhaba till Arab armies
become garbage answer one day Madan will
fill the girls shoes in the meantime he
leads his team of honey hunters into the
jungle
[Music]
the team braids and Bree secures their
handmade rope ladders then they've
ventured to the cliff side where the
beehives are hiding the team creates
smoke fires down below to encourage the
giant fees to scatter
Madonn lowers himself onto the Rope
dangling hundreds of feet from the
ground
Oh Moira and elkanah tell a league or
very much a varsity team Amara meanwhile
a acrimony gratitude telling America
stole a tamale given ear by or about a
delegate at le meriden mother bunny poor
Emily what is it amalgam I get my limo
team despite the incessant stinging on
his unprotected skin he calmly cuts away
at the hive fulfilling his duty and
securing his liquid gold forever daddy I
have a dingy dirty fancy but it's
offered it around a little deliver him
the hives are collected by the hunters
and packed up to bring back to the
village where their safe return is
celebrated yo Ramiro Genma Diego de Lima
Mira Bobby Lea and Lea neither a
Malaysians actively any other corny
porta young Willie you you can wear
animal attack damage Santa you put on
Ronnie Kalen butter our pork only
whatever you Maura can challenge a vaca
Roger this is the dictator scorpion
growing up to eight inches in length it
is one of the largest scorpions in the
world for its colossal size the dictator
scorpion has relatively weak venom so
for defense it resorts to its enormous
claws they help it to catch prey and
ward off other scorpions located within
the region of West Africa the dictator
scorpion is nocturnal spending most of
its life underground sometimes burrowing
as deep as six feet
unfortunately size doesn't matter when
it comes to the preservation of the
dictator scorpion with their natural
habitats being destroyed by
deforestation its future is uncertain
this is the dictator scorpion
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
on the internet the other day I found an
animal that looks like something quite
familiar they've tried to block the road
but outside of the road one sure turns
out this fluffy looking caterpillar that
looks super soft is actually super
poisonous so I called dr. Wagner
he's an entomologist up at UConn my
specialty is Lepidoptera which is the
study of butterflies and laws this
caterpillar it has a few names
well it's mega l'apicio perky Alerus
most people call this animal the post
caterpillar except in the south where
many people call it the ass these
caterpillars are distinct because
they're covered in what looks like long
soft hair only mammals have true hair
and then what we find on insects are
really derived scales underneath those
it's where the poison spines are there
may be a little bit like a hypodermic
needle when you pet the caterpillar it's
quite a wallop I think of all the
caterpillars in sting that ass may have
the most painful and most toxic sting
that poison can cause headaches swelling
nausea blisters even difficulty
breathing and in case you were thinking
that these guys probably live deep in
some jungle you would be wrong they're
found mostly south as an Asian victim
line on a research boat usually it's the
new guy who gets the dirtiest job this
time is no exception
I'm Wes Larson a wildlife biologist and
lover of the outdoors for as long as I
can remember
I'm traveling the country to find the
next generation of conservationists the
people on the front lines of the fight
to understand our planet and protect the
animals we share it with
[Music]
we've got a pretty big hermit crab today
I'm headed to Sarasota on the Gulf Coast
of Florida it's home to a beautiful a
little understood animal the spotted
eagle ray I'm joining up with the
research team from Florida Atlantic
University and Mote Marine Lab there's
some of the first scientists in the
world to study this animal in depth so
Brianna what are we doing today so today
we're gonna attempt to visually spot
some spotted eagle rays bring it on
board take a bunch of samples and then
we'll release it back into the wild
I'm Way excited Brianna deGruy is a
master student at FAU she's been
obsessed with race ever since she was 11
years old she's leading the field
research today spotted Eagle razor
pretty understudied we really don't know
a lot about them right yeah there's not
a whole lot of information about just
even their basic biology or ecology so
what do they mean for the environment
how are they affecting the environment
how many of them are out there and from
an environmental component they're
really important to keeping the
ecosystem in balance so it's really
important that we understand basic
questions about them which is what we're
trying to do here
[Music]
grow up on the spotting tower point the
view up here you can definitely see into
the water a lot better than you can down
there
they stand out pretty good we're gonna
go over the grass bed right now
a tendency to hide in the grass what
we're looking for is there a large
enough to surgically implant a tracker
and it takes an experienced eye to spot
one right there yeah I believe so that's
him that's him
that's an eagle rated be ready
catching array is a complicated maneuver
we have to completely encircle it with
the net or the ray will escape and
you've got to be quick about it
the water is really choppy in these
maneuvers that they do with the photo
really dress it once we've got it
surrounded we need to bring in the rave
and he's in the middle he's going to the
north this ray turns out to be tiny just
a juvenile my job is to hold it in place
while the team does their work despite
its size it's not easy as soon as we
flip them over you can really see how
much just calm down that's the state
that they go into called tonic
immobility it's kind of like the Rays
hypnotize a lot easier to work with any
money when he is on his belly we get
there are quite a bit bigger than this
right yes we get to be about seven feet
I want to send this ray is too small to
surgically implant a tracking device
so once we've gathered what data we can
it's time to let him go
and while the spotters keep an eye out
for a big ray we take a break from the
hunt
when you begin researching an animal one
of the most fundamental things to
understand is its eating habits and to
figure out the Eagle race the team has
come up with a creative solution
[Music]
Breana this is kind of what we're
looking for exactly this is a gastropod
yes or for the layman we take back the
snails and clams to the lab where the
team has two wild rays in a holding tank
we're gonna put some free items into the
water and we're going to record the
sounds that they're making while they're
crunching down on the hardshell prey
items and we're trying to decipher if
these different prey items are making
different signature sounds by tracking
the sounds at different shells make when
the race crunch them the team believes
that they can decipher the Eagle race
diet and that's big just crunched it
there exactly yep but the hope is to put
these listening stations out into the
environment and we can know exactly what
they're eating when they're eating it
and how much they're consuming as the
captive raised crunch away we get word
that another has been spotted offshore
that's bigger so it's time to head back
into the Gulf for one last attempt to
catch a big one we just got word there's
another spotted eagle ray got double the
size of the ones that we currently make
so we're on our way to go relocate it
and hopefully we'll get another right
hand for it it's pretty clear when the
team grabs the other net that this is a
much bigger Rea unreal
this raised over five feet wide from
wingtip to wingtip plenty big enough for
the surgery Brianna's hoping to do my
job
holding the Rae upside down and
perfectly still while she implants the
tracking tab position for you to raise
this so preparing all of our surgeries
supplies to do an internal acoustic
surgery it's a really quick procedure
where an internal tag is implanted into
their belly area and it allows us to
follow their movements as they travel up
and down the coastline sharks and rays
don't feel pain the same way humans do
and with the Ray on its back it stays
calm and relaxed throughout the
procedure
yeah that's quick
the surgery is over in just a few
minutes this tag will allow the team to
track her for years to come
giving them a detailed picture of where
eagle rays live and how far they travel
putting us one step closer to
understanding this beautiful animal I
come from a mammal background and
working with mammals there's kind of
this natural connection that you have
with them and I didn't really expect to
have that sort of connection with these
rays but when we pull them up onto the
boat I felt this intelligence coming out
of them they're very personable animal
yeah that's the reaction most people
have they're highly intelligent and
obviously their beauty and grace just
helps us to form another connection to
them I've heard people say there isn't
much mystery left in nature but eagle
rays remind me that there are still
animals we know hardly anything about
answering the basic questions can help
us better understand them and in turn
protect whole ecosystems watching this
discovery firsthand was a true privilege
it makes me wonder what other hidden
secrets must be waiting out there
you